hello and welcome to a very special
episode of the app clinic today we're
broadcasting our pilot episode of the
GDG app clinic starring talented
developers from Prague we thought it
might be fun to visit Prague but we can
get the budget so instead we invited one
of the Prague GD jeez to join us via
hangout we gave each developer a few
minutes to introduce their app and then
it was our turn to give candid feedback
on how to make their good apps even
better we're hoping to repeat this with
GD geez all over the world so let us
know if you want to be part of the magic
but be warned check developers know what
they're doing so without further ado
welcome to the GDG app clinic Prague
thank you very much for inviting us to
your to your GD g in Prague I'm a big
fan of praha I love the city been there
a few times not just for Google
developer days but for fun as well and
one of the things which I always come
away from whenever I go to Prague is how
great the developers are one of the big
reasons why google has a big interest in
what happens in in Prague so we really
honored to have this opportunity to take
a look at some of the apps that you guys
have put together hopefully give you
some feedback and just basically hear
from you guys as well as to you know
what you've been working on and you know
what inspires you about Android so and
I've been to Prague once on the way to
burn oh that's pretty much a great okay
so let's invite our first speaker hey
hey guys nice to meet you it's a
pleasure to kick off this fantastic
event so I hope we get some great
feedback so our application is called
big launcher as the name suggests its
launcher suitable for seniors for people
who are visually impaired and for
disabled people it uses the big icons
and large text for all the basic
functions of the phone including
contacts including messaging including
call log and also it can launch
applications so this is big launcher
upon a giant giant phone and it exactly
as the developer said owned by the way
make sure you guys introduce yourselves
when you get started as well so we know
what to call you what is your name sir
yeah I'm young all right perfect so
agent great name do these a great name I
feel like we're not going to be able to
pronounce any of the names today so we
started about as simple as it's going to
get and it's going to go downhill from
here nonetheless Jana has done a great
job here you can see big launcher is
exactly what it says it's a replacement
launch screen
and it is exactly that so it's got nice
big buttons bright icons really easy to
see what's going on one of the things
that I did find was during the
configuration process there's a setup
wizard that you go through and as part
of that part of that process it feels
like that's actually quite complex so
it's almost as though it's an app that
you're going to want to set up for
someone else rather than have sort of
the visually impaired or all the person
set it up themselves that's kind of the
impression that I got I don't know how
else you can do it really because
obviously the you're going to have some
steps where you have to dig into the
stuff that's in the phone already you
know even at least just to set it up as
the default launcher so that's that's
something that you may want to consider
is you know what is the target audience
for that phase of the app so if that's
more for your sort of expert user so
yourself for whoever who's setting up a
phone for your parent or grandparent
then you may want to try and make that a
little bit more familiar to sort of the
standard phone UI and then keep the sort
of large scary and simplified stuff for
the for the final home screen itself
there's also a couple of tips about the
wizard setup process itself it doesn't
quite follow a standard wizard type you
I so in a normal wizard I want to be
able to go navigate backwards and
forwards until I'm complete and I
noticed that when i was doing this setup
i had to simply progress it was just
sort of a series of questions that got
put up on screen i answered them i chose
my default whatever else and moved on
now if you're setting up if the idea
here is that it is for the older person
to use themselves and that kind of makes
a lot of sense you don't want to have to
put too many buttons on screen too much
confusing navigation just one big
question make a decision move on to the
next part but i'm not sure that they it
quite work it was a little bit too
complex for that use case a little bit
too basic for the more expert user one
of the things that i noticed through
that wizard process as well as that
you're able to select a language or go
fly the default now i was a little
confused by that because the phone is
obviously going to have a language set
you can have the different resource
folders to make sure that the correct
assets are loaded was there a particular
reason why you wanted to allow people to
select the language independent
the phone itself yeah there's a reason
because we feel that some of users can
have a different different language set
in the in the system settings but they
want to use a different language in a
lawn chair itself for example some
immigrants or people like that so that's
why that's true I think if I were
setting up this phone for my
mother-in-law who's Chinese I think that
I I would want the set up to be in
English but she of course we want ads
you gonna have the launcher in Chinese
that makes a lot of sense right I'm
learning stuff myself so when I me when
I'm actually using the app so you can
see here that the buttons are responsive
which is nice whenever you building
custom buttons custom UI it's really
important to make sure that they behave
the same way that standard Android
buttons work and so you need to have
some sort of feedback when you're
pressing things what I did notice which
would be interested to understand better
is generally for stuff like this it
might be useful to have a long press
which triggers the accessibility by
default on sort of the jelly bean on the
phone so the same way we're on action
bar
what it is that actually actually does
that usually he felt like the long press
was unfriendly to this type of user yeah
and it could be so how does one triggers
or the accessibility talkback functions
of the phone well there are there are
two two things the first is that sinner
people got problems got problems too to
distinguish between one press and short
press so we we wanted to get rid of that
and then during the development we got
this idea or the the possibility to use
a long press for for some other function
so you can turn on in the accessibility
options that on long press the big
launcher reads the deactivated the
actuated item this is useful for older
for other phones with previous versions
of Android which doesn't have the
explore by touch function so even even
on these low older phones people can use
this read by touch or read by a long
press function developed by us and they
can be for example be reminded of what
this what this icon does so when you
create a shortcut for some application
you see only the icon but when you long
press on it the the description of this
icon is right so you will remember what
it does very nice very nice so I mean
overall is it's not a huge amount of
feedback that we can give apart from
getting a little bit nitpicky I think
that the the padding around the time and
date along the top up here is a little
bit narrow you probably want to indent
that a little bit more to make it feel a
little bit more
balanced but really a lot of the
feedback is going to be that kind of
nitpicky stuff so we're going to make
sure we include that in an email and
send you officer of those details we're
going to get Roman Nick and Adam from
the Android design in action team as
well to provide a little bit of extra
feedback on on sort of UI elements to
this happen and all the ones we look at
today rather than spend too much time
complaining about two pixels being
missing from a particular part of the UI
although I did have one comment on the
clock I was a little surprised because
I've always been told that digital
clocks were less accessible and that
older people would prefer analog clocks
but you used a digital clock here I'm
wondering was at it conscious decision
well it's again because of the support
of Flores devices and older phones
because you don't have too much space on
on phones later the very 240 x 320 so
yeah good point it's it we also if you
turn on the option in preferences there
is also enlarged battery indicator and
mobile signal indicator and we are
really getting low on space there yeah
that's a really good point that makes
sense so okay so a couple of very quick
last-minute points so it does have an
old-school venue button which does
display a custom more easily pressable
menu I suppose I'd like to say I
understand why you've got this
particularly for backwards compatible
support for all the devices I did note
that you still have the menu button and
it is a little more shameful in the
wizard there's no need to have it
available there and here I would think
about having a default mechanism on
newer versions of the device which get
rid of that menu button so i know that
there is a setting within the setup
wizard which lets you optionally choose
to have you no preferences show up
within the UI itself i'd consider
defaulting that too on and hiding that
menu button away it just will make the
appt look more polished on your device's
make people feel like it's a more
polished final
act and the other piece of suggestion I
would have as well particularly around
it seems like you having to make a lot
of you I compromises and choices based
on what makes it easy to use by older
people I would if you're not already
strongly suggest that you make sure to
use a lot of analytics to find out
exactly what people are doing are they
long pressing are they then heading back
what one of the behaviors one of the
choices one of the outcomes of some of
those compromises we did lots of testing
with the UI itself but we currently we
don't include any analytics in that
because again it's it's about the target
group we we suppose that lots of sinners
don't have data tariffs or mobile data
at all so we've created this from the
beginning to be to be completely offline
application great well I can't argue
with that and it sounds like you've
thought it through so uh yeah nicely
done that's the thing I we could go on
praising it but that doesn't seem so
that's great well actually I sorry I've
always got one last thing but you've got
a really good point that that you don't
want to use the data tariffs but have
you considered maybe doing analytics
anyway and just storing it to persistent
storage so I feel like especially in the
scenario where you have a care giver
that's that's a setting up the app and
then you've got the senior that's using
it it might be useful to have that data
even offline 22 just debug issues yeah
and you can also do things like you know
store up the analytics are only uploaded
when it's connected to Wi-Fi this all
those things might much which all of you
should be doing anyway that's that's
right that's a really important step all
right I think so thank you thank you
very much great app will I send you
through some tips but basically nicely
done I think this also thank you very
much for the offer feedback circles all
right who's the next victim next victim
I wikked him
hey next application is a stock's
tracker great hello guys baby so now my
name is to Marvin Dragic come on show
classic okay cool shortly Tom for you
great that's what you do with the way
more our speed thank you so much comedy
okay so let me introduce my application
that i published few few days ago it's
nine stops tracker so throw name
suggests it's about stocks so one day I
bought a stock here to practice okay
change and I wanted to watch it all the
time with my phone but by the time there
was no application that could provide me
data from practice okay change so I
decided to make my own up alright
perfect alright so sick look so one of
the things that I really like about this
app is just the story you told us of
having a need that you wanted to have
fulfilled and then building an app that
fulfills that I think a lot of the best
apps come from people who have a problem
that they want to solve from themselves
and so they build an app which does that
and I think that's a great way of
knowing what you use is want if you're
your phone your own first customer so
let's start it up you promised it would
be really quick as soon as it started so
let's boom yeah pretty fast all right
now nice so this is a really nice app
what I really like about this is how
you've followed the Android design
guidelines in a way that makes it really
easy to use really familiar but it still
has its own unique look and feel so if
we look at the the front page here we've
got our own and we've got this sort of
custom little thing down the bottom here
which is giving us the nasdaq index nice
little graph control they're all of this
is custom there's nothing like this
built into the platform so that looks
really nice it's really pretty and it's
a good use of space there too because we
you know we've always said don't put too
much on the bottom because you don't
want to accidentally press something
when you're trying to hit the back
button in the home button and so it's
nice to see something there that
you know visual and important but
doesn't have to be interacted with too
much is in fact honestly the only
problem that I had when I first picked
up this interface I was looking for the
search button mmm today I sort of
expected it to be up its top and instead
it was up at the bottom no it's a
perfect icon you know that search with a
little plus like oh that's how I add a
stock I no worries there as soon as I
found it it just you know it took a
little while yeah to find it because it
wasn't in a place i expect it feels like
it should be in action so that may be
one piece of feedback is to extend that
bottom part out move the button up to
the top yeah I also you know I we
usually say don't put a refresh button
yeah it's possible I've got a little bit
so as I had a little of a look to see
how the Refresh worked and it seems that
you've got and within preferences you're
able to select your refresh frequency as
ever I see that sort of thing I get a
little bit nervous so I need to oops I
feel like I need to up how are you doing
your roof room Oh pick your pardon yeah
sorry how are you doing you're you're
refreshing well though the application
starts alarm in particular interval it's
not not waking up alarm so it's a it's a
inexact repeating non like a line like
that not repeating but I set alarm every
time I need to schedule next update okay
so one of the things about that if you
doing that yourself and it's not
repeating then it's going to trigger it
basically the exact time so you may want
to consider setting an inexact repeating
alone even if you then disable the alarm
each time and reset it that'll give the
system a little bit of leeway to time
shifts you're all the alarms from the
different apps and make sure that
they're not waking up the cell radio
sort of within a few seconds of each
other and keeping the radio hot and
draining the battery more quickly uh-huh
if you want to think it an even a step
further given that you said you have a
server where you're remembering what
people's stocks are so if you wanted to
be really really battery efficient
really really awesome you would actually
do all
the parsing of the stocks on your server
and then use Google Cloud messaging to
tell each of the devices which have
those particular stocks listed that it's
time for a refresh in fact because the
stock data is so small you could
probably bundle that within the payload
so you wouldn't actually need to do any
refreshing at all you can just tell the
devices goog is up ten percent and have
it updated so it it wouldn't mind if
there was a lot of messages a lot of
push messages from server to all those
ups no we have apt social media apps
like Twitter clients and and and
messaging apps like you know instant
messaging apps all use cloud to device
or Google Cloud messaging cream there's
no quota very efficient definitely
definitely the way to go okay so that's
something to look at I think that's
going to definitely the biggest piece of
feedback which is going to really
transform this app it's going to make
it's going to reduce your latency it's
going to increase your battery life it's
going to let you hide away these refresh
buttons so I think that would be a
tremendous asset from the UI perspective
you know I was worried we don't have the
Android design in action guys here Rome
and Nick those guys are kind of the
experts you've done a great job a lot of
these apps it's on a fantastic job you
look here we've got we've got the tab
strip along the top and so you've got
this really beautiful view pager
implementation so you can switch between
the stock exchanges they've even is that
your owner did you borrow that from the
from the apps page on AOSP / coop island
well I just noticed that the 3d effect
here and I wonder if that's if that's
the AOSP implementation or did you do
that yourself notice it's simple page
transformer that is available in support
library so nothing special it looks
looks really nice yeah and what really
impresses me is you've got a view pager
and you've also got the correct
implementation for the drawer pattern
like correct in every way it displays
correctly it comes in and out correctly
just really really nicely done so Bravo
we so rarely see a correctly implemented
drawer pattern even with some Google
Apps so it's impressive uh-huh and
you've got the right details here one
possible nitpick you've got settings an
account
within the draw not entirely convinced
that's the right place for it i think
the draw is better for just navigation
so all these other things stocks
portfolio indices and market news
perfect but i'd consider moving settings
an account back into the overflow menu
over here next to select markets and
possibly even switch them around move
select markets into the potentially move
that into the navigation drawer but
these these two things settings and
accounts are things which you would
rarely change you'd set up once or twice
maybe in the beginning and then never
see them again so you want to move them
out of the general UI and hide them away
in the overflow yeah in fact you know
things like select market I might even
want to see in the settings yeah you
know it basically settings is a really
good place to tuck away things that you
don't expect to be used particularly
frequently so when you go to select
markets I mean you're basically i figure
that not being an international super
trader i'll probably set up a couple of
markets and you know then forget about
them and just switch between them I I do
think that it was a little a little
confusing in terms of how you know a
difference from the stock apps that i
normally use to have to remember which
market each of my stocks is listed on
that might be more of a us thing where
we've got nasdaq and the new york stock
exchange and we don't really think of
that I mean they're treated the same for
tax purposes I don't really think of
them as being different so you know I
looked for a couple of stocks and I can
find them and it turned out they were on
the wrong exchange that may be a really
useful search feature so that when you
are searching to add it works across all
of the exchanges that you have selected
it's not a crush every exchange but just
the ones which you are interested in it
might be really useful not good I
noticed when Ian added the Prague stock
exchange it has a whole bunch of default
stocks set up I really like that because
it was actually one of the feet pieces
of feedback that i had was when you
first start up the ad you
the app you end up with this screen
which is perfectly fine tells you to add
stock but it's kind of almost cheating
because it's asking you to add stock
using a button which you will never be
able to use again so it's almost
training the user to use the app the
wrong way I think it would be really
interesting to instead have a few
default stocks so that you sort of see a
screen like this when you get started
immediately understand how the app works
and then looking to add your own stocks
which you then do using the button which
hopefully will be at the top another
thing that a lot of apps do that I think
I like a lot I think it's particularly
helpful is if you do have empty space in
your list what you can do is put the
outline of another item which then if
you press it it will take you to the add
page you know so because that's the
thing is when I look at these a sock you
know the first thing I think is how do I
get more things into this list and if
the button is right there it's very
intuitive as opposed to you know down
here in the corner where it's certainly
visible but just not as into it
otherwise it like I said really really
nice that you click through you have the
the stock details here nice again custom
graph which you know shows the stalk
much better over that time frame and
then you can click again further through
and I quite like this because you can
actually annotate the graph and and save
that and and even share using the
standard share intent which is all
really really nice one thing I did
notice obviously you have the ability to
zoom in and out using the you know the
buttons at the top I was kind of always
looking to zoom and pan left or right
you know within within this so it's kind
of screaming out for a gesture of some
kind and I think we actually have an
Android training class around gesture
support so maybe we're dressing a look
at that considering it I've built so
many graph implementations and so many
different program languages over the
years so I know how much of a pain it is
to implement that sort of second level
of zooming and panning so not a p0 not a
high high priority bug certainly the
faster more efficient updates is more
important but as a nit picky thing which
might be really nice you know I don't
think I've seen any stuff that's a lot
too because do that I've built many
graph layer that I think it's actually
very easy well Jim you back yes we all
know who's a better program so yeah see
I've taken a few notes I just want to
see if I'm if I missing anything here I
think we've covered pretty much
everything I wanted to write up the the
thing that I I think we have to point
out and I don't know how well it comes
out in the video is just how fast this
app is it's nice man yeah really really
quick and I put a lot of effort to make
it fast yeah and it's paid off like you
know project but a big part of what we
do with the framework now trying to get
everything to be snappy fast and smooth
everything in this app is you know
updates there's never any jag never any
latency everything just sort of works
which is really nice you know portfolio
stuff here again tells you how much
money you've theoretically made you know
go back to stocks it's all just fast and
quick and intuitive so congrats nicely
done we'd love to if if you I do get a
chance to implement the google cloud
messaging we'd love to hear about that
because i think at that point this could
be a nap would share we could talk about
featuring so yeah yeah nothing it's our
choice but we can certainly talk to the
people history well we we certainly do
have the ability to get into the pure
Android that's true says he's looking
pretty pure Android but uh yeah so once
yeah I think a couple a couple of little
changes and getting rid of the refresh
button and go into a different refresh
cycle that would be because we need to
stock up and we totally need your stuck
a pin this this is nice yeah definitely
keep in touch let us know how you get on
and we'll see ya an ad Hong Kong and
Shanghai okay thank you very much thank
you thank you very much the next speaker
is application SMS ticket hello everyone
my name is hundred me I'm from in my
company and I'm happy to introduce last
update of SMS ticket which our team has
just released just
today let me say a couple words about
the use case because you might not be
that familiar with it let's say I want
to take a bus or tube in a crock what I
need is a ticket and i can buy a ticket
in in a shop or in ticket vending
machine or i can send a special text
message to some special number like this
a lot of the engines and props after a
minute or two i receive a text message
which i can officially use as a ticket
perfect and what our application does it
remembers all those codes and special
numbers for you so you can in three
clicks you can send or you can send a
text message you will receive the text
message back the application parses
validity information from from the
ticket or set some arms to warn you 10
minutes before ticket expires or fires
notifications and save so the ticket in
the database for later reference later
on you can see how much you spend on
tickets in detailed statistics i'll let
me say just some numbers we have about
eight hundred eighty-three thousand
users and about every second user uses
the application activity and we support
22 tickets in 9 check and for slovak
cities what do we cook for a future we
would like to add push notifications to
keep the database of ticket database up
to date and we would like to add a
widget widget to make the order of the
ticket just one click experience nice
okay i'm pleased to to be here and I
would appreciate any feedback thank you
oh yeah thank you for thank you for
coming along so I like
I've been to Prague a couple of times
for Google developer days and the folks
from inmate are always impressed if you
guys do some really good work so it's
wonderful to see I think two apps from
you guys nominated today SMS ticket
we're going to be able to be pretty
quick on this because it's actually
really good um I love the simplicity I
love what you guys have done you've got
your custom branding this sort of golden
orange color which is really distinctive
and it pervades the entire UI in a way
that is kind of subtle but really
effective it's it's obvious what your
brand is icon coloring and everything
else really works once you're in the app
again you have sort of this really
subtle user guide so that you know what
you're supposed to do you know tells you
right here you can choose to look at the
list of tickets or statistics by a new
tickets that the whole process is laid
out for you in a way that doesn't feel
too obnoxious I don't need to click past
that I don't need to go through a wizard
it's just there if I order a ticket you
know again you given the cities all of
this detail so we'll go with Pilsen and
then you can again it's just this really
simple click process everything's really
obvious 35 minutes buy a ticket and
again you've even customized the color
of the the text in this dialogue now
normally I wouldn't be convinced that
that's actually a good idea but it kind
of works here yeah close she's just
discipline is authentic and that's kind
of the key like we always harp on about
how important it is to follow the
guidelines don't change the standard UI
in ways that will confuse users a lot of
people assume that means that they have
to create apps that look exactly the
same as all of the standard apps it's
not what we mean I just mean that they
have did that I've been orange so why
don't have orange dialogues or sure it's
exactly just blue dye orc in fact I you
know if you've ever seen our game review
show it's just sadly off the air right
now but you know one of the things that
we would heart bond is when you'd be
playing a game and would all of a sudden
pop up a standard system dialogue and it
took you straight out of the game now so
having a skin for those dialogues and
making it feel like it's part of your
app without doing too much rearranging
or alteration of the functionality
is a great idea absolutely so if we
tried by ticket we can't because we
can't send an SMS which is perfectly
appropriate you guys have happily oops
have happily sent us a special version
where we can add a test ticket so thank
you for that that definitely makes our
life easier and boom there you go you
have a ticket really straightforward 12
minutes a little orange indicator saying
that actually you're going to need to
use this ticket pretty soon so that's a
really good indicator to make sure
people you know what you're doing here
is adding value above and beyond what
they would have gotten if they're just
looking at their SMS texts in their SMS
viewer you know change that metaphor
presenting them with a ticket and now
it's turning red because I guess it's
within 12 minutes we can click here we
can see the valid to and from we can see
the code and I guess the code is
important because I'm guessing you have
to show that to two conductors or what
have you if they they cost you demanding
to know if you've paid for your ticket
mm-hmm so you go you can show the SMS
itself right okay perfect so that can
all be validated all consistent what I
really like here is they've actually
used notifications really really
cleverly so you have this notification
and it's a rich notification so you're
able to show the SMS which again you
need to do if someone wants to know that
you've got a ticket got the details and
it's got a an icon here which if we
continue to prattle on which we will
this will become red um it's like I
scripted it so it's red which means hey
you've got less than probably 10 minutes
before the ticket expires so you need to
get on and use it really really useful
really really effective way of using you
know notifications now again this is
non-standard your that I could the the
guidelines say that the notification
icons should be black and white small
etc but no no I disagree I disagree
because the the guidelines actually say
they should be monochrome yes you can
take that that's true in you know
there's only one colors any one color so
like I can't argue with that but again
it's it's a really practical way of
showing more information in a way that
just makes sense you go well obviously
it's going to be this
really what else would a face so I grew
again really nicely in fact the only
thing that I was surprised about that I
kind of wanted to be different is I
would love to have the SMS and they the
important codes show up in a much larger
font I imagine myself you know needing
to show that to somebody and just my day
is going to go faster if it's about two
or three times as big as everything else
okay I'm sure every single person in dog
or it uses the app you know everyone in
product or you've used as public
transport is using your app anyway so
the conductors are totally going to get
used that's true no that's a good point
it would be nice to make it more visible
you know same thing with the order
ticket but I think that could be bigger
and a little further away from the
status bar I think that would make me a
little more comfortable and we might be
useful to emphasize the actions that you
want people to take or the information
that they may need and make that a
little more obvious you I nitpick if you
have tabs you should be able to swipe
between them so you want to have that
view pager implementation on the front
page just swipe between tickets and
statistics I don't know why we do tabs
without view a tourism yeah we should
just not allow it yeah so that's that's
the only other sort of nitpicky as well
when you've got the notification so
you've got when the ticket will expire
valid from code I'd almost want to
change it around a little bit so that
you had again made it a little bit more
obvious how long until it expires so
you've got that countdown is indicated
by red I just want to see like 10
minutes five o'clock you know whatever
the those two numbers are should be kind
of the you know made Baldur made more
obvious yeah the orange stands for like
20 minutes then the red one stands for
term for the last 10 minutes and then it
goes great for expired ticket side nice
and beautifully once once i'm done with
my ticket i can i can swipe it away
probably after it's expired is that
right mmhmm yeah that is that explains
why i can't get rid of it so that's fine
and i'm guessing i haven't actually
tried adding multiple tickets yeah nice
add lots of tickets
I'm testing you for that works that
works nicely now one thing that you may
want to consider though is that if I do
have a lot of tickets and that's in
fairness probably not a very common use
case I risk flooding my notification bar
so you may want to consider collapsing
that in so that it's just got the latest
one and the total number of tickets you
know how would I one can say that if
you're traveling with your family for
instance you know you might buy four
tickets to the same place yeah but we
still can group them yeah exactly you
don't them by expiration time something
like that I think that was really oh
that yeah that would be great see and
they do dismiss yeah perfect so yeah
nicely done no check to see if I have
any additional notes not really i think
the only real issue we had was was the
swiping between tabs everything else is
nitpicky hopefully you'll find some of
that useful you know but totally your
call yeah of course I mean what one
argument for not swiping between the
tabs is that if if you can dismiss these
tickets by swiping them away it might be
hard to distinguish between a swipe on
the ticket I'm swipe between tabs but I
think what we're what we're really
asking people do now is an edge swiat so
if you've got something where the you
know you're swiping internally then it's
understandable that that gesture
wouldn't switch between tabs but an edge
swipe always should yeah the stock trak
iraq but we just looked at actually does
this really well for bringing out the
action the draw at the side it does sort
of an edge swipe for that which works
really really well perfect alright so we
shouldn't spend too much more time on
what is already a really nice app you
want to be able to take a look at a
couple more in the time that we have
available so thank you very much really
nicely done and yeah let us know how you
gonna yeah thanks a lot
thank you the next speaker needs to jump
a little bit have to get here okay so
the next application is a swim places
sorry hi guys Hey so just to let you
know I'm not a developer in charge of
the project management for airport and
I'm this big person spokesperson for for
them I'm going to talk about our app
that was conceived together oh by the
way my name is Eureka that's one of the
tough names mmhmm yeah yeah sort of
everyone was my name up on all other
people's and this this ad was originally
conceived by our maids collects who
designed the application for some places
and one day when we decided on a hot day
when we decided to go swimming and we
couldn't find anything we didn't have
the computer with us we decided that
we're gonna create the app it's a good
idea it's it's a non-commercial
community app which basically allows and
provides the users with the option to
add places that they love or discover
new places that they haven't visited yet
the target group is pretty much like
wild swimming enthusiasts but also that
doesn't mean skinny dippers but it also
does include them it's not against them
it's not for them but they're welcome
excellent yeah they're welcome to use it
yeah all right let's take a look yeah
you can't be can't judge my country
Jenny one's preferences on me so I guess
one of the quick questions I did want to
ask so it sounds like all of the places
they get added based on your community
so it's you're not sourcing data from
anywhere
else you're asking your users to add
places as they visit them is that
correct correct it's correct for first
couple were added by us the most known
ones but then the community picked up
and basically is in charge of adding
everything perfect okay so that's and
that's what we can see so if we look at
our list so i like that it knows where i
am and and gives me nearby places based
on my location but it didn't turn on the
gps at least not that I noticed so it
was all done quite quickly quite quietly
I don't feel like it's draining my
battery for something which it shouldn't
need to so that's that's a really nice
touch that's good you know these these
sorts of apps you will really need very
accurate location to be useful exactly
Chris this one draws a pretty wide we've
got all the way down from from San Diego
up to Seattle yeah Madison Park DJ I
know that place my uh one of my best
friends lives two blocks from there well
he was my best friend until I found out
his his wife was working on the Kindle
Fire project okay yeah what are you
gonna do tell your friend to add more so
so that's kind of a problem in terms of
using it is just that we don't obviously
there's not a big community of swim
places users yet here in the bay area
because i'm pretty sure that there is a
beach closer than Pismo Beach you don't
want to swim around here it's awful yeah
that's so actually not in the bay anyway
it's so cold here there's beautiful
Pacific and we've got the bay and you
will just die then again I'm talking to
people in products so I'm guessing if
you enjoy outdoor swimming you don't
have a problem with getting cold now app
looks nice I think overall I think
you've obviously got a color scheme
going you've got the blue it gets
perhaps a little too blue here and that
you've got dark blue at the top that a
lighter blue for your tabs and then a
lighter blue for each list item and then
a slightly darker blue for distances
what it means is that your contrast is
getting a little washed out if the app
sort of seems to almost fall on itself
where the bits of white become almost
too pronounced so this little white bar
that says places around me in the tiny
tiny text seems more important than it
is because it's the only one of the only
pieces of you I that isn't
whoo so you want to be really careful
about how those color choices and that
color template can affect the way that
people are looking at the app overall I
feel like the list items they feel a
little bit too narrow I'm not sure how
high they are but they feel like they're
a little bit less than 48 pixels I'm not
quite as good at Roman when it comes to
picking exact pixel heights but it feels
a little narrow possible yeah possible
it's a really small thing but it makes
it it makes a real difference in terms
of how easy it is to click on things and
to navigate through the app so you want
to make sure you're at least 48 the dips
in height for anything that you want to
touch probably well again like on the on
the last step we'd really encourage you
to use a viewpager so that you can swipe
between those tabs you just at this
point that pattern is so common that it
feels wrong when it's not there to me
right and then the action bar I think
yeah so it's an interesting choice i'm
guessing this is a split action bar
implementation I'm not entirely sure but
it feels like these buttons could just
as happily live at the top as part of a
sort of the standard action bar I'll be
basically there at the bottom since we
couldn't really fit them and next to the
next to the tabs that are already on the
top and it changes when you flip it sort
of into when you flip at 90 degrees it
changes to MN goes to the top okay and
that makes sense so you are using a
split action bar it's a legitimate
pattern it can be it can be at times a
little bit disconcerting to have the
things along the bottom it is a standard
pattern so I can understand why you've
done that you know again you probably
want to see if you can lose the refresh
button it doesn't seem like an app
that's going to be refreshing data so
rapidly that a user is going to want to
have to manually do a refresh you kind
of it makes sense an instant messaging
or an email where you're waiting for an
email so you keep pressing the button I
think the update rate for this is going
to be much slower so you're better off
doing maybe a server push again using
google cloud messaging when something
gets updated
you send it out to all the phones to
tell them hey there's some new locations
you may even want to include the
location of the newly added spot in that
Google Cloud messaging payload so then
the app only needs to do an update now
if that location is near where the user
is so if it's a thousand kilometers away
don't worry we'll do the update later if
it's right next door hey maybe that's
going to be interesting to them so
unless you're phenomenally wealthy true
if you don't like a new got a private
figure going that's yes Sergei would use
that shopping but other than that for
the rest of us not so much your list
views as well so you've got a lot of
content in each of these and it seems
like some of it may be duplicated so I'm
not entirely sure what the icons on the
left mean I'm guessing it's the kind of
place so the seashell means the C the
Loch Ness monster means a lake is that
the idea it's uh yeah okay so you were
that's really nice I really like that I
like the visual nosov it makes it much
easier to see at a glance I like you
both color-coded and yes it look at you
and a color which is yes but it does
mean you're duplicating data so I don't
need to see the word see next to the sea
shell like you should just train your
user so that they understand that that's
what that means and certainly when you
click through to details it's useful
then to say what it is just so that you
know they can learn what those different
icons me but on this main screen I want
to see the name of the beach be a bigger
basically make it easy to read easier to
see that's the main piece of information
that you're trying to pass on same with
the distance I think yeah exactly
especially you know here where we've got
some beaches that are relatively close
and then some that are very far away it
would be useful to have the distance a
little more scannable absolutely one
other thing that you may want to do so
if I navigate in I have the ability to
hit map or navigation really nice touch
I would consider adding the navigation
action to this main list view on the
right hand side because if I was using
the app that's a lot of time that's what
i'm going to do so i am driving up
driving up or down the Pacific Coast and
I want to watch the sunset at a beach
you know I'm going to take a look at
this looking for all the pink things in
the nearest one I find I'm just going to
get
get to find out how to drive that so
again this depends on your use case and
this is a really good example of why
analytics can be useful to find out what
percentage of your users are going
through here and straight away clicking
navigation if that's a common use case
and that's something you want to promote
and similarly trying to decide and this
is kind of good advice for most
developers decide what do you want we'll
use us to do what are the main actions
what counts as success so do you want
them to go through and read as many of
these as possible or add photos or use
it to navigate what are those primary
actions and make that as simple as
possible for them to achieve right as of
now we mostly want them to add as much
information as possible upload photos
the navigation is just a candy nice to
have okay I get that and so that that's
that's good advice right so then what
you may want to do is consider adding
one of those actions to this main screen
so that you can say oh I'm at that beach
you know so you just open it up you go
oh the one of the top is where I'm at
and have the button there to add photos
directly from it now obviously that
introduces a new I challenge you're
making it a little bit more cluttered so
you may only want to add that button for
the item at the very top of the list but
it something just to consider like you
want to reduce the number of clicks
between the user opening your app and
performing whatever action you want them
to perform so similarly and you've got
the ad here which images for adding
places obviously that's the main thing
that you want them to do to build up
that community so that may be another
example of why leave why you may make
sense to have that sort of at the top
because when most people are opening the
app they're expecting the main actions
to be up here and so by not having it
there it makes it a little bit less
likely that they hit that plus button
you may even want to go a step further
and if that really is the most important
thing for the app is to have a big
button somewhere maybe above the list
view which encourages them to do that
first and foremost now I wouldn't always
do that but you can tell how important
that is so in Prague you've got probably
most of the important swing places there
a strong community it's less important
so definitely don't show it to people
prog here in California they're missing
most of the things here are missing and
so I open this app and I go well this
isn't actually that useful to me because
there's nowhere nearby but if the first
thing at the top of the screen was
actually a button asking me to add
places well that I can do I know a bunch
of places around here that i can add
it's a great point i'll do add them i
will i will see that in action on it for
myself um but that's that's my point is
that you want to make it obviously the
user what what do you want from me to do
and then I can decide whether that's
something that is useful and interesting
for me so maybe have a look if there's
nowhere within 100 kilometers you know
make that the main option just so you
know please help grow our community
people do love that sort of thing so
that maybe maybe something to consider
good point now for the added screen I
this just this might just be me but I
really feel like you'd get a better user
experience and possibly more additions
if the first thing was a map the map
because you have this nice you know
positional thing I advise what I what I
really want to do is the first the first
thing is i want to point to it on a map
and then fill in information the problem
with this screen is that the very first
thing I see is three or four text boxes
and the on-screen keyboard and that
immediately says to me oh my god I'm
gonna have to do a lot of typing and I'm
not into it right now I think I'll just
go and do something else yeah it's a
good point because this is what you get
straight away all you see is the text
and you're like I just wanted to think
so what in seeing is a really good point
if this was the very first thing so as
soon as you click in here you see a map
with an icon next to a quarry or a lake
that I'm in it's like okay great so I
click that and then the next thing I get
is it asked me for a name and stuff and
hopefully as much of this as optional as
possible so that you can just say yeah
it's the Pacific Ocean and I still have
the places that you know that they can
look up an API from Google Places API
that allows you to search for points of
interest you may be able to use
something like
that to help make suggestions for users
I don't think I'm a bottle fill yeah I
don't think you're able to use the data
itself but you can use it as a way to
suggest places that people can then fill
in the data themselves but do check the
API terms of service because I don't
look at them in the wrong direction
there otherwise I mean all this is
really nice you sure you want to cancel
ah this is a really interesting dialogue
do you really want to cancel all
inserted data will be lost if I hit
cancel it doesn't cancel because it's
cancel to cancel be careful for that all
right we got a bug right there yeah so
make sure that you're getting that right
make sure that the I always forget what
the correct button order is here I think
you've got it right but make sure that
you've got the the yes no in the right
order it's all detailed in the style
guide you know and maybe I'm stay and
leave would be better than cancel and
leave in this case because yeah you just
want to objective things which is clear
which button is going to make you go
away in which button is going to make
the go away but I go away mm-hmm also I
would suggest not showing that dialogue
if the user hasn't it I actually entered
any it's a great one if you haven't if
there's no data to lose then there's
there's no reason not to just let them
back out and in point of fact unless
that becomes non editable later it would
the absolute best user experience is if
I haven't entered any data leave without
prompting if I have entered data save
that data and leave without prompting
and then allow me to delete the data
that I've entered if it turns out that I
didn't actually want it and that covers
the the ninety percent use case with the
least amount of injuries of dialogues
otherwise you know all of the details
are reasonable the only issue here i
have is you've got this custom colored
buttons along the bottom here in this
example i'm not sure that it does make
sense they just think feel a little
garish the colors are really strong
particularly around defaults this makes
me think defaults may do something
really bad big bright red button like
seriously read I think that's too funny
I know it's like composing in gmail
that's dangerous
you see me they want to kill Syd makes
it seem like these are the two most
important things on the screen and that
show is going to do something magical
whereas all it's really going to do is
apply my filters right which is
perfectly appropriate but I don't think
that there's any it's don't think it's
necessary to have have them differently
colored let's see soups so this is one
of the different dangers of having all
of your actions right at the bottoms
it's really easy to accidentally click
the wrong thing yeah so I totally did
that on purpose to demonstrate that
point search would be nice to have
searched as in line so that an action
bar search rather than popping up its
own screen particularly that way you can
you know you can see what is already
there before you start searching and
having autocomplete you know in that
would be nice and I actually feel that
way about filters to I think it's a
little harder to do but especially when
your filter is just a list of checkboxes
if you can pop it over you know like
drop it down from the top or put it in
the bottom so that you can see the the
results absolutely one thing that you
may want to consider trying so i'll be
i'm not entirely sure how useful this
would be given that we don't have so
much local information but it might be
interesting to apply filters by
basically pivoting on what the
information that you have and so if i
click on the seashell icon you know i
hit the icon specifically maybe that
just shows me all of the seas so it does
apply that filter that way rather than
having to go through the second screen
again i think that's something you
probably want to be the test with people
to see if they if that means that they
get lost and they don't know how to go
back but something like that as a way of
being able to click here i get a list of
all of the lakes and if i hit back it
takes me back to the main screen it's
unfiltered i think that will be really
interesting i would get lost on the list
it might be okay with that on though on
the second screen seconds yeah yeah it
was let's talk it's interesting yeah
again basically the what we're trying to
come up with here are ways to reduce the
number of clicks to implement any
behavior so the problem here is if I if
I hit filter that's one and then I have
unclick a bunch of these so that I can
just get the one that I want I can do
you know one two three so it's sort of
taken me four buttons to get there and
it doesn't actually look like it
supplied by filter which is upsetting
also yeah I'm sort of wondering why I
have a long list of filters with text
when I thought you were training to me
to use these really pretty icons you
know and and if it had been with the
icon you might even be able to group
them a little closer together my main
issue with the text is that you've got a
bunch of checkboxes you have to scroll
up and down to actually use the filter
you don't want to pack things tightly
and make them impossible to use but
let's say that for instance if you had
just the buttons that you could turn on
and off right you know you were
highlighting them is in some ways it to
make them active and inactive right so
uh a new microphone this is he blowing
out your ears every time he does that
apologies I need to figure out something
but again just you know so I can rising
the amount of scrolling would be really
great yeah I could literally see that
just a big box at the bottom of your
results list with all those icons in it
and i could just turn them on and off
and see the results immediately that
would be awesome that would be magical I
think would it be magic it could be
magical okay he knows what magic is
right yeah so otherwise really nice I
really like the community aspect I like
the the general you I like the
functionality huge potential I think
there's a few little little things which
could make a big difference so we're
going to you know again we're going to
put some of this new picky stuff in an
email send it through so that you have
all of our feedback in one place I'd
love to see how you get on that some and
add some local swimming spots I promise
yeah it's really cool it just last thing
because we say this about any app that
has community is you might want to think
about hooking in
two more community so having having some
more information about your users maybe
hook into Google+ you might think about
it thank you can consider a google plus
log in sleep or share the swimming
places with with your friends your
circles or whatever be kind of cool all
right nice thank you so I think very
well thank you very much thank you um ok
thanks a lot so I would like to thank
both of you for participating in this
and organizing this with us we are proud
to be first GDG in the world to host up
clinic would thank you for thank you
very much for having us its media it's
been really rewarding really interesting
and great to see that product developers
continue to be some of the most talented
of app developers in the world so thank
you for giving us obviously we didn't
hate yes thank you you don't know how
hard our job is sometimes today it was
easy thank you